nos dicen si 5 se divide en piezas de un
medio de entero cuántas piezas tenemos
en total esta expresión es equivalente a
decir cuánto es 5 dividido entre un
medio también nos ayudan a visualizarlo
acá abajo así que pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo cuántas piezas obtienes si
divides 5 enteros entre piezas de un
medio
bien vamos a trabajarlo juntos bueno en
la recta numérica vamos desde 0 hasta 5
y arriba tenemos piezas de un medio de
entero cada una esta es una pieza de un
medio así que cuántas de estas piezas
tenemos para obtener 52 bueno dos medios
hacen un entero y tenemos cinco enteros
entonces serán cinco por dos lo cual es
10 y podemos verlo como uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
piezas por lo tanto diez medios hacen
cinco enteros entonces cinco dividido
entre un medio es igual a diez perfecto
hagamos uno más
bien tenemos una pregunta similar nos
dicen si tres enteros se dividen en
piezas de un sexto de entero cuántas
piezas tenemos en total una vez más
pausa el vídeo y piensa lo bueno
realmente es de mucha ayuda que nos
pongan este dibujo observa tenemos tres
enteros uno dos tres y vamos a dividirlo
entre piezas de un sexto de entero aquí
tenemos un sexto acá otro un sexto acá
otro un sexto etcétera si seguimos esta
idea podemos ver que hay seis sextos en
un entero por lo tanto en tres enteros
tendremos 6 12 18 de ellos o bien puedes
contarlos uno por uno y verás que el
resultado es correcto si tomas tres
enteros y lo divides en sextos cada uno
de los enteros serán seis sextos por lo
tanto tres enteros serán tres veces seis
sextos o dieciocho sextos y hemos
acabado nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo